The acronyms API get's thrown around
a lot in the computer science community,
but what is an API and
why is it so important?
Well, APIs
are Application Programming Interfaces
refer to any method of communication
between two entities of code.
You can think of APIs as
connection points in code
that allow one application
to talk to another.
When you copy code from a browser and
paste it into a word
processing application,
an API inside your computer helped
make that transfer of data happen.
If you listen to music on your computer,
like with Itunes or
Spotify, the music-playing application
communicated with your operating
system's API in order to send
that music to your speakers.
APIs are a great way for
controlling the exposure of code,
allowing internal functionalities
of an application to be used
from the outside world without
exposing all of the internal code.
Companies that want to keep
their code bases private,
like the makers of Microsoft Windows or
Mac OS X,
use APIs to make it possible for their
applications to still have interactions
with other applications without
having to reveal the actual code.
Even for open source code projects, like
the Ubuntu operating system, APIs make
easy entry points to code that other
developers will most frequently use.